hey guys i'm ryan right and i am dance
ever we're gonna be checking out the
video today for just cuz three
hahahahaha dude I would put this [ __ ]
out of like yeah cuz cuz why'd you do
that just cuz that's not what this game
is like but no [ __ ] just causes a
cool game open-world environment is that
the technical term that is the technical
term but thank you thank you I'm
learning open-world environment
grant that thought over you're like art
they should make one with Archer dude I
played a [ __ ] up a torch archer game if
there if it was like Archer commentary
the whole time but in Jessica's style
that would be so much fun - oh it was a
tall-tale games ha you probably don't
know what it's sure I do
this game is anticipated to be rated
mature of course anticipated we expect
this to be unseen 17 maybe it's cuz of
all the boobs we prohibited
- feels like bond intro this feels like
fair living a Las Vegas
[Music]
this is one in traitor right this is
great this is awesome
[Music]
Wow
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ] lucky for a face dude dude so
good Wow
we got real it looks I mean sure we
didn't get gameplay but I love like that
opening that theme they have going on do
those sweet it's like modern day spot it
is so cool I was really [ __ ] sweet it
gets you excited to see like because
it's a perfect setup of dictator versus
spy like what's worse than a [ __ ]
dictator
I mean um two dictators to dictators I
would say three but then they might just
kind of like resolve themselves what do
you call a dictator that touches himself
um my dick touch her masturbator
dictator Oh masturbator jokes we got him
I'm sure the gameplay will be similar in
a lot of its own ways and just more
hiding a little bit more controls you
can use but as far as like what they're
trying to set up with like visual aspect
here that was really cool I hope we get
more involved with like more story stuff
to also squirrel suit squirrel see the a
squirrel suits a squirrel suit dude it's
gross it's awesome because I mean that's
what the the last game was all about was
like throwing that grappling hook and
like running around everywhere and then
parachuting around and this time it's
just nice to eat it's pretty ugly [ __ ]
it let the squirrel suit your way to
victory that's why I love games because
that's a bunch of [ __ ] I would not do in
real life no hell no I went flying
squirrels who thing no [ __ ] cool that
he come that guy but that's not god
that's not me no that ain't me that's
why I play games anyway guys thanks for
mentioning that was out if you're new to
the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects and you could check out
Dan's gaming channel that's right here
yeah if you have a computer it's right
there oh phones it doesn't appear haha
check the description yeah check the
description Dan's gaming channels
awesome seriously saying that
because seriously saying that seriously
seriously just cuz just come check it
out a Just Cause and you can follow us
on Instagram and Twitter you can do that
it's in the description box still feels
weird saying that but people have
pressured me and says mentioning that
you need social needle network stuff
fake Capone press the baton as a
youtuber it is my job to be in
connection with the fans see it in my
posting pictures and tweeting stuff I am
connected to the fam yeah we can take a
selfie right now from the camera and
people will be like what episode did we
do oh well [ __ ] do anyway yeah we're
going to do with this right now where's
your phone would you put your phones
weird on my phone shoutouts will
continue to go to facebook.com watch the
real reject shoutouts where you can
trigger a shout-out by saying something
interesting like Dan's handsome Dan's
handsome that's that that is okay so
we're going to Instagram in the episode
are we afraid